et is finding out more details about  brad pitt and angelina jolie's divorce  and custody battle a source tells us  Angelina has been super aggressive with  her approach while Brad wants an  amicable split Angelina wants to make  matters public quote he wants to handle  this privately whatever is best for the  kids not for him is what matters ET  previously confirmed the estranged  couple reached a temporary custody  agreement that will remain in place for  three weeks which includes the therapy  and random drug testing you think the  story's gonna have a happy ending happy  endings of stories and haven't finished  their sources familiar with the  agreement told ET at Brad's first visit  with the kids will be monitored to  determine whether the actor will have  future unmonitored visit Angelina filed  for divorce after two years of marriage  with Pitt earlier this month asking for  full physical custody of the pair's six  children